what is the shadow docket on the supreme
court well effectively there are two
different dockets or lists of cases
before the supreme court there are the
merits cases on the merits docket where
the court will entertain extensive
briefing the parties will come in and
have oral argument before the court and
then they will issue a long opinion
agreeing with one party and disagreeing
with another party that's the normal
process the merits docket and then there
is the shadow docket which is largely
made up of cases that are asking for
emergency relief from the court they're
saying that they can't wait for a
mayor's decision so they ask for an
emergency temporary restraining order or
an injunction from the supreme court
often in these kinds of cases that
emergency relief is the whole ball game
so if you're dismissing this thing and
not granting the emergency relief then
there's no point in going forward on a
merits decision as of the last four
years the supreme court has been using
the shadow docket to dispose of cases
without having any presidential effect
and often with no opinion whatsoever no
explanation of why they held the way
that they held and that's probably not
good for anyone